Er hier kann sich innerhalb von Sekunden selbst heilen.
Und er hat ein metallverstärktes Skelett. Und er hier hat so krasse
telepathische Fähigkeiten, dass er jede beliebige Person auf der Erde ausfindig machen kann.
Aber wie realistisch ist das überhaupt?
Tach zusammen, Jack Pop hier!
Wir können gar nicht mehr zählen, wie oft ihr uns schon gebeten habt
dass wir uns die skills der X-Men mal genauer anschauen sollen.
Wie bitte? Was sagst du?
Godzilla sagt, es heißt eigentlich X-Men.  Heute ist es also soweit.
Aber bevor es losgeht: Sagt Ihr noch mal bitte, welche Mutanten-skills, welche besonderen
Fähigkeiten hättet ihr denn gerne? Lasst mir mal einen Kommentar dazu da.
Lass uns mal mit Wolverine anfangen. Logan musste ja für sein Skelett und die charakteristischen
Klingen ganz schön einstecken. Bei der OP dazu wäre er nämlich fast draufgegangen.
Autsch. Wolverine überlebt die Prozedur dann zwar doch, aber was genau haben die da bei Weapon X
jetzt mit ihm gemacht? Also in dieser Gen-Forschungseinrichtung? Wie immer im Marvel-
Universum gibt es da in den Comics, Serien und Filmen verschiedenste Erklärungsansätze.
Fakt ist, am Ende wird sein komplettes Skelett mit einer Metalllegierung überzogen,
nämlich mit dem fiktiven Adamantium, das im Marvel-Universum als unzerstörbar gilt.
Die erste Frage, die sich mir da gestellt hat, die hängt mit dieser Szene hier zusammen. Da sehen wir
nämlich, dass das Adamantium heiß und flüssig in Wolverines Körper gespritzt wird. Und wenn
Adamantium sich schmelzen lässt, dann ist es ja nicht mehr unzerstörbar. Also dann es ist unter
physikalischer Einwirkung mindestens verformbar und damit auf jeden Fall anfällig für Hitze.
Diese Frage, die wird auch in der Fanszene heiß diskutiert. Und eine mögliche Antwort findet
sich im Marvel Handbuch Band Zwei. Da steht nämlich, das Adamantium als Legierung natürlich eine Mischung
aus verschiedenen Chemikalien ist. Und wenn man diese Zutaten zusammenpackt, dann hat man ein
Zeitfenster von acht Minuten, indem sich Adamantium tatsächlich verformen lässt, wenn es auf
1500 Grad Fahrenheit Hitze gehalten wird. Das entspricht ungefähr 816 Grad Celsius. Aber
wenn diese acht Minuten rum sind, dann lässt sich Adamantium eben nicht mehr verformen. Selbst wenn
es dann noch mal die gleichen Temperaturen erreicht. Nicht okay, so weit, so gut. Aber selbst mit
dieser Erklärung, und wenn wir jetzt mal hinnehmen, dass das Adamantium wie in der Szene hier super
zielgerichtet sich ausschließlich über die Knochenstruktur verteilt, haben wir trotzdem immer
noch ein Problem: nämlich die hohe Temperatur an sich. Denn mit dem heißen Metall steigt natürlich
auch Wolverines Körpertemperatur. Hier hat er schon 100 Grad Celsius.
Und wenn ihr euch an eure letzte Fieber-Episode erinnert, also wenn man so mit 40
Grad Fieber im Bett liegt. Das ist halt einfach super unangenehm. Aber wusstet ihr auch, das bei
44 Grad Körpertemperatur schon sämtliche Enzyme und Eiweiße kaputtgehen und dann der sichere
Tod eintritt? Und was die über 800 Grad heiße Flüssigkeit mit dem umliegenden Gewebe bei
uns machen würde - also darüber müssen wir, glaube ich, gar nicht sprechen. Es gibt also einige gute
Gründe, warum wir in der realen Welt kein heißes, flüssiges Metall nutzen, um unsere Knochen zu stärken.
In der Medizin nutzt man bei Knochenbrüchen und Osteoporose, also wenn die Knochendichte abnimmt,
Metallplatten und Schrauben. Und im Moment sind die vor allem aus Titan. Aber auch das
ist interessanterweise nicht unproblematisch. Denn so ein Metall, das hat natürlich ganz
andere Eigenschaften als Knochen. Es ist zum Beispiel viel weniger elastisch und deswegen
können Belastungen, die auf eine Stelle wirken nicht mehr gleichmäßig verteilt werden. Das kann
dann im schlimmsten Fall dazu führen, dass der Knochen geschwächt wird und sich zurückbildet.
Das heißt, Patientinnen und Patienten, die so ein Implantat haben, die müssen dann oft nach zehn
bis 15 Jahren noch mal operiert werden, um diese Implantate zu ersetzen. In der Wissenschaft sucht
man deshalb Materialien, deren Eigenschaften besser zu denen von Knochen passen. Und da ist
man unter anderem auf metallische Gläser gestoßen. Die sind ein bisschen anders aufgebaut als reine
Metalle und sind dadurch deutlich leichter. Und man kann sie auch präziser formen und damit
wesentlich besser an diese Knochenstruktur anpassen. Die sind trotzdem so hart wie Stahl
aber eben gleichzeitig so elastisch wie ein Kunststoff. Trotzdem muss man sagen, die lassen
sich nur ganz gezielt einsetzen und könnten leider nicht das gesamte Skelett ummanteln,
so wie das bei Wolverine der Fall ist. Also noch klappt es so wie bei Marvel leider nicht.
Okay, Logan, der überlebt die OP auch nur, weil an dieser Stelle dann seine Mutation zum Einsatz
kommt. Er hat ja diese krassen Regenerationskräfte, also sein Körper, der ist in der Lage,
sich innerhalb von wenigen Sekunden selbst zu heilen. Sogar wenn sein Herz aufhört zu schlagen.
Sich selbst zu heilen, das ist jetzt in so einem Superheldenkosmos natürlich keine Seltenheit.
Auch bei Marvel sehen wir das an verschiedenen Stellen. Hulk kann das, Deadpool kann das. Und über
den haben wir ja auch schon mal eine eigene Folge gemacht. Die verlinke ich euch hier oben. Und damals hatten
wir schon über die Realität gesprochen. Denn Selbstheilungskräfte finden sich auch bei diesen
kleinen süßen Kerlchen hier: den Axolotls. Die haben die Fähigkeit, ganze Gliedmaßen nachwachsen lassen
zu können, und sogar innere Organe und Teile von ihrem Herzen und ihrem Gehirn. Was wir damals
auch schon besprochen haben, ist das bestimmte Aspekte dieser Fähigkeit sich auch bei uns
Menschen wiederfinden, zumindest im Kleinkindalter. Denn da kann zum Beispiel eine abgetrennte Fingerkuppe
von alleine wieder nachwachsen, wenn die Wunde nicht vernäht wird. Diese Fähigkeit
zur Regeneration, die verliert sich aber nach ein paar Jahren. Und die Frage ist jetzt, kann man das
ändern? Und da gibt es interessante Erkenntnisse von Forschenden der Universität Harvard. Die haben
sich nämlich Panther-Würmer angeschaut, die auch die Fähigkeit haben, große Teile ihres Körpers zu
regenerieren. Die Forschenden haben bei denen genau das Gen ausfindig machen können, das
dafür zuständig ist. Das haben Sie dann deaktiviert. Und siehe da, die Panther-Würmer konnten sich
plötzlich nicht mehr regenerieren. Interessant ist, dass die Forscher das Gen in einem Bereich
gefunden haben, den man Junk-DNA nennt. Und zwar weil man immer gedacht hat, dass dieser Bereich
keine besonderen Funktionen erfüllt. Beim Menschen macht Junk-DNA tatsächlich 99 Prozent unseres
Genoms aus, also 99 Prozent, an denen kaum geforscht wird. Das könnte sich jetzt aber ändern, denn die
Harvard-Leute glauben, dass sich auch in uns drin ein Gen befindet, dass die Regeneration von
Körperteilen und Organen an- und ausschalten kann. Und wenn wir diesen Schalter wirklich finden, dann
wäre es vielleicht tatsächlich möglich, dass sich unser Körper von selbst heilt. Auch wenn es jetzt
vielleicht nicht in der gleichen Geschwindigkeit passieren würde wie bei Wolverine.
Ein Problem haben wir am Ende aber immer noch. Die Selbstheilungskräfte können vielleicht
erklären, wie Wolverine diese krasse Skelett-OP überlebt hat. Was so aber sicher nicht
funktionieren würde, wäre diese Szene hier: Das springt Logan nämlich direkt nach der
Behandlung aus dem Becken. Und er wiegt schon ohne sein Adamantium Skelett 88 Kilo. Und dann kommt das
ja aber in der Prozedur dazu. Dann wiegt er plötzlich 136 Kilo.
Das wäre ungefähr so, als würdet jetzt ihr in einer Wanne liegen und jemand würde euch einen vollen Kasten Bier auf den Brustkorb packen
Also das geht gar nicht mehr. Also, wenn ihr es doch noch schafft, so dynamisch aus dem Bett zu springen,
dann schreibt mir es mal in die Kommentare. Das würde ich nämlich voll gern sehen. Aber bis dahin müssen
müssen wir festhalten: in der Realität funktioniert das halt einfach überhaupt nicht. Es schafft es nur so ein Typ wie der Wolverine.
Kommen wir jetzt mal zum Chef, also dem Mann, der bei den X-Men quasi alle
Fäden in der Hand hält, Professor X-Xavier. Der kann nicht nur Gedanken lesen, er kann sogar
seine eigenen Gedanken in die Köpfe anderer Menschen projizieren. Der kann Menschen in den
Dornröschenschlaf versetzen und im sogenannten Cerebro jeden Menschen und Mutanten auf der
ganzen Welt orten. Ziemlich krasser Typ also. Aber gibt es solche Fähigkeiten auch in der realen Welt?
Mentalisten wie Timon Krause, die leben davon, anderen Menschen zu suggerieren, dass sie ihre
Gedanken lesen können. In Wahrheit stecken da verschiedene Prinzipien dahinter, die wir
teilweise schon in unserer Magicologie-Folge besprochen haben. Die verlinke ich euch mal hier
oben. Unter anderem ging es da um das Forcieren. Da gibt der Mentalist einem den Eindruck, eine freie
Entscheidung zu treffen. In Wirklichkeit trifft er aber die Entscheidung für uns, weil er uns schon
längst beeinflusst hat. Dann gibt es noch das Cold Reading. Bei dem nutzen Mentalisten in so interviewartigen
Situationen bestimmte Techniken, um beim Gegenüber den Eindruck von schon vorhandenem
Wissen zu erwecken. Wichtig ist, dass alles beruht auf Tricks und besonderen Fähigkeiten, Menschen
sehr gut lesen zu können. Aber telepathische Fähigkeiten sowie die von Professor Xavier,
die gibt es nicht. Und das sage ich nicht einfach so. Denn es gibt methodische Tests, mit denen man das
tatsächlich untersuchen kann. Zum Beispiel mit den sogenannten Zener-Karten. Das sind Karten
mit fünf verschiedenen Symbolen. Wenn eine Versuchsperson darauf getestet werden soll, ob sie
die Reihenfolge der Karten, die eine andere Person aufdeckt, durch telepathische Kräfte vorhersehen
kann, dann liegt die Rate Wahrscheinlichkeit bei fünf Karten bei 20 Prozent. Wenn diese vermeintlich
telepathische Person jetzt einen signifikant höheren Anteil richtig angeben kann, dann wäre
das ein Hinweis auf Telepathie. Und auch, wenn es immer wieder Berichte oder Untersuchungen gab,
in denen vermeintliche telepathische Fähigkeiten nachgewiesen wurden, so sind diese Berichte und
Untersuchungen dann immer wieder in die Kritik geraten und haben vor allen Dingen einer Wiederholung nicht
standgehalten. Also das ist in der Wissenschaft ganz wichtig: Dinge müssen reproduzierbar sein.
Wenn man also denselben Test unter den gleichen Bedingungen erneut durchgeführt hat, dann kamen da
unterschiedliche Ergebnisse raus. Bedeutet, es gibt bis heute keinen einzigen Nachweis für Telepathie.
Und das, obwohl verschiedene Organisationen sogar Preisgelder ausschreiben für einen Nachweis
von solchen „parapsychologischen“ Fähigkeiten. So zum Beispiel die Gesellschaft zur Untersuchung
von Parawissenschaften hier in Deutschland. Die bietet Personen, die ihre besonderen Fähigkeiten
im Test beweisen, ein Preisgeld von 10.000 Euro. Das allerdings sind Peanuts im Vergleich zu dem, was in
den USA möglich ist. Bis 2015 war dort das höchste Preisgeld für so ein Test je ausgeschrieben,
nämlich 1 Million US-Dollar, wenn man seine übernatürlichen Fähigkeiten wie Telepathie da
irgendwie im Test beweisen konnte. Aber seit 1922, seit Etablierung dieser Tests, war noch
kein einziger davon erfolgreich. Oh schade, gerade
Gedankenlesen wäre in so vielen Situation total
hilfreich. Ich wüsste nämlich zum Beispiel jetzt schon, wie ihr diese Folge findet. Also seid doch
bitte so lieb, schreibt es mir einfach in die Kommentare. Und wenn er dabei seid, drückt doch
bitte auf abonnieren und unsere Glocke. Dann verpasst ihr nämlich keine Folge mehr.
Und wir können uns schon bald bei bald wiedersehen. Ich freue mich darauf. Bis dann. Tschau Tschau.
Wer fischt die weltbesten Popel? Es ist Logan, der kommt bis ganz nach oben. Nach diesem Dreh bin ich ein richtiger X-perte. Wo sind meine Snacks?... Ich muss sie treffen…